12 months have passed since the first
kobit-19 cases emerged in germany
meanwhile the virus has claimed more
than 56 000 lives here
more than 2 million have been infected
and the number keeps climbing
over the past year we've had to adjust
our day-to-day lives to a new reality
that we could hardly have imagined
before
it's been a whole year since the
prospect of a family holiday has become
a remote possibility
even impossible a year of keeping our
distance from friends
colleagues even our own families
and every day we witness the
consequences of the pandemic
restaurants shattered inner cities
deserted
public life has come to a standstill
[Music]
welcome to our kobe 19 special i'm
monica jones and berlin good to have you
with us
5608
that's how many new coronavirus cases
were registered in germany over the past
24 hours no big deal we've had worse
now imagine hearing a german saying that
a year ago
unthinkable but 12 months of this
pandemic
have changed us here's how it started
germany first came across coveted 19
here at the offices of this automotive
supplier in bavaria
it's where a 33 year old employee caught
the novel virus
from a co-worker who had traveled to
germany from china
he became patient number one
german officials were quick to assure
the public the country was taking the
virus seriously
but that there was also no cause for
alarm
health minister yen spahn told the
public there's no need for exaggerated
concern
the world health organization echoed
this with calls for simple measures like
more hand washing self-protection is
still the best
possible way we can go about this
but infections spread to every region in
germany
contact tracing became impossible
germany's hold on the virus gave way to
the free spread
of covet 19.
then just six weeks after the first case
was discovered
germany announced the closing of schools
by the end of march a nationwide
lockdown meant the workplace
and the school day had to compete for
attention in homes across the country
the bulk of people in germany seemed to
take the restrictions in stride and
agree with them with the budding spring
germany slowly started opening up again
but by the start of may nearly 7 000
people in germany
had died meanwhile elsewhere in europe
the numbers ranged from more than 24 000
to over 28
000 deaths in comparison with many
european neighbors
germany appeared to have weathered the
height of the crisis fairly well
many people enjoyed the warm summer
months
but then fall arrived and cases began to
rise again
by november a so-called lockdown light
was in place
despite both calls for stricter measures
as well as protests against them
but the mini lockdown didn't work cases
rose at alarming rates
with more and more patients needing
intensive care
by the christmas holidays restrictions
had been tightened again
and after the new year schools and shops
remained shut
the latest extension of germany's
lockdown will continue
through february 14th
after more i'm joined by emelia buma
she's an infectious disease expert at
the bavarian health and food safety
authority
and she's been involved in analyzing the
new coronavirus right from the start
when it first emerged here in germany
good to have you with us
please tell me when did you know what we
were dealing with
it was the very beginning of last year's
january when
a colleague of mine sent me the link to
the who
report on germany cases of unknown
origin
in wuhan china and he asked me matt what
do you think about these cases
are we going to expect something really
big here
a news ask maybe and i said well no i
don't think so definitely not
oh how wrong i was it took a while for
the rest of the population and
authorities to revise the views
i mean i remember that i was flying from
munich airport in late march
so much much later than those first
cases emerged still before the lockdown
though and the security team there was
tested positive and we were all there
without masks
i mean dealing with that situation a
year ago it was learning by doing right
well every outbreak investigation is
kind of learning by doing
why is that so because um
because every outbreak is different you
have to adapt
your methods um you have to adapt
the measures uh you implement to stop
the outbreak
and um yes it's it's always
a unique situation but of course last
year that was
very special very unique and to be
honest also
very exhausting and challenging and and
still
it still is it's it's ongoing uh
and even a year into the pandemic now
we're now in the second year already
we still find it hard to say where a
person
got infected and that's significant why
is it so difficult
well uh with as you said with
ongoing virus transmission and
we have observed really intense virus
transmission and circulation
for several months now it's really hard
to trace back
infection chains why is that say
because on the one hand
it takes some time and effort to
um to reconstruct transmission chains
and well the the public health
authorities have been working at their
limits for some time now
and their priority is to
um to prevent forward
transmission meaning that to prevent
further
spread of covet 19
and also many cases do not know um
where they got the virus from and
there are also some cases who do not
want to say
where they've gotten from yeah and all
of that makes it more difficult and on
top of that of course now we have the
variants
uh that are said to be even more
infectious than the original
virus so it still feels a little bit uh
like learning by doing
how has the pandemic changed your life
well uh in in many ways of course it was
a very challenging year for me
professionally and i have two kids it
was also
with regards to to my private life very
challenging with homeschooling etc
but also uh what i want to say
i have never been so thankful for all
these
brilliant work scientists do
all over the world to develop a vaccine
that's effective against the novel virus
within
12 months or even less than 12 months
it's just brilliant and
what i want to say is that if you get
the chance to
um get your uh coverage shots
when it's your turn to get the
vaccination do it
for your own protection and also
um protection of your fellow
human beings right that's certainly a
new chapter in the pandemic
uh the vaccination male boomer from the
bavarian health and food safety
authority thank you so much for your
time
thank you monica and it's
uh time now for your questions over to
our science correspondent derek williams
when will we get back the normal life as
we know and lived it until the end of
2019 i decided to answer this on air
because
i'm asked the question so often and by
pretty much
everyone and you know what i can't give
you an answer
no one can i can only guess and you know
what else
no one can see the future so what all
the experts out there predict
is just guessing too though some guesses
are of course
more informed than others so so that
said
here's my best guess it's based on
two factors that should be clear to all
of us by now the first
is that the only way to return to some
kind of normal
is through vaccination the second
is that means worldwide vaccination
until we're all protected we all remain
in danger the current flock of
variance has revealed how quickly this
pathogen can cross
borders and the longer we leave it in
wide circulation
even if it's in other countries the
higher the chance
it'll mutate into a variant that can do
an
end run around vaccines so vaccination
programs have to be fast
and they have to be global i see it as a
numbers game how much vaccine can we
make
how quickly to reach herd immunity
everywhere which many experts say is
around
70 of humanity that's around
five and a half billion fully vaccinated
people
um since many vaccines require
two doses let's call it 10 billion doses
for this back of the envelope prediction
i added up
what makers of different vaccines
currently in use
are now claiming they can produce in
2021 which as far as i can tell
is around 8 billion doses so not enough
to round the corner globally by the end
of this year
um granted those numbers change
constantly but there's still
no question it'll also take
time to distribute those billions of
doses so
right now i just can't see a return to
something approaching global
pre-pandemic norms
for for at least a year and and probably
a lot longer
though in individual nations with high
vaccination rates things will likely
grow
more relaxed before that maybe as early
as this summer
best guess
you